as a homeschool mom I had a ton of stuff
little manipulatives games
cards all of the things
and I needed a good place to store them that was easy to pull it out
I could see what I had but it all had to be in the same place
and I found this photo box on the TikTok shop
that has 18 little boxes inside
that are the perfect size to hold all of my games
I have these little napkins I worked on last week
and they fit in here so nicely
I also have all of these like
math cards these are math facts for them to work on
and they also fit right in this container
it fits so well I can store everything in one place
and I can just pull them out so easy
when I need an independent activity for my kids
so if you also are a homeschool mom
and you're looking for a way to store all the things
you wanna get this photo storage box